the u.s president joe biden has
confirmed that the leader of islamic
state has been killed in an operation in
northwestern
syria uh residents and activists
reported multiple deaths including
civilians
from the attack
and the
opposition syrian civil defense also
known as white helmets said at least 13
people were killed including six
children
there's a statement that uh has been
released by president joe biden in which
he says
last night at my direction u.s military
forces in northwest syria successfully
undertook a counter-terrorism operation
to protect the american people
and our allies and make the world a
safer place
thanks to the skill and bravery of our
armed forces we have taken off the
battlefield abu ibrahim al-hashimi
al-qarashi the leader of isis all
americans have returned safely from the
operation i will deliver remarks to the
american people later this
morning
may god protect
our troops so uh just to reiterate that
breaking news uh president biden has
confirmed that the leader of islamic
state has been killed in an operation in
north west
syria